let's bring you some breaking news out
of Iran at least 15 people have been
killed in Shiraz State tv says three
gunmen opened fire after entering a
popular shrine
Wilson Javari joins us from Tehran so
what can you tell us about this attack
dorsa
well according to the
the police chief
Forest Province who was just speaking to
State media on the phone he said that
there was one gunman who carried out
this attack in a shrine that is known as
the king of light Shrine it's one of the
most well-known monuments in the city of
Shiraz in fars Province there's one
gunman according to the police official
was shot by by security forces and he is
in police custody at the moment he also
said the police chief that they have a
number of casualties and a number of
people that are in critical condition at
the hospital currently so he didn't give
an update on the number of people dead
so far but we have heard from various
other officials that have put the death
toll so far at 15. what we know about
this area in Shiraz it's a very
well-known Shrine to Muslims in the
country and around the region that come
to the city for many reasons tourism and
pilgrimage being those main top reasons
this Shrine very very well known not
only inside Iran but across the world
the last time there was any kind of an
attack in the city of Shiraz was in 2008
so 14 years ago when there was a bomb
planted in a mosque that went off
killing 14 people there has been no
events or any incidents since then and
at that time Iranian officials arrested
three people who were later convicted
and executed as of this for this
incident that took place around 6 PM
local time insurance we have not heard
anything about a possible motive or who
is responsible other than this one
attacker if he has any known
affiliations this is a very rare
incident to be taking place at a very
important time in Iran when security is
at high alert given the number of
protests that have been taking place
across the country but certainly this
latest incident a unprecedented really
in the recent years especially in the
city lecturers where many tourists go on
a regular basis not only from within the
country but from around the world
all right thanks so much Dr Jabari there